so when I said I would speak I didn't
know what I was going to talk about and
then Ken said I was going to talk about
the state of go and so that's what I'm
going to talk about which is great
because I actually have a lot of things
to say about that
but I thought the best way to talk about
today is to start by talking about where
we were yesterday and I thought it would
go like right back to like Hal go was
originally received in the very first
months you know back in the end of 2009
and so I looked at the girling nuts
archives from that time and I noticed it
like within the first few days these
threads popped up and they were you know
very very long threads hundreds of posts
a peach a piece a peach and then there
were more complaints which persisted
kind of to this day in various
incarnations and this is the first happy
news thread maybe you can't see it but
this is this is only the section that
was to do with braces and indentation
and it was by far it was like 7/8 of all
of the posts were in this thread and I
like the way it actually indents so at
the end it was like two words per line
on the page which is kind of fun but you
know within the first couple months we
also had some historic moments the first
public language change was Rob's
proposal to remove semicolons by popular
demand it's a great idea and it was I
also wanted to mention this because I
think it dispels this myth that a lot of
people like to perpetuate that the go
team doesn't listen to what people say
about go and what they suggest the truth
is actually that we we really do listen
to
everything it doesn't mean that we
necessarily agree with everything that
said and I think some people assume that
means we haven't heard them because the
argument is infallible but in this case
you know it was an obvious win to drop
the semicolons which we did gladly and
the language is much better for it and
it's not the only example another early
point of contention was the logo so this
is a post going this you know it's
obvious he loved by at least someone but
I didn't like it if anyone has a good
idea
I'd like to come up with something less
well no offense
etc so I got the guy that kind of
rolling his eyes here and if that comes
across but the great response that I saw
in that thread which came really early
on with someone saying oh I found an
appropriate logo but I need someone to
render it in line line out and this this
picture is that which I thought was
great there were also some really astute
posts where people kind of got it
straight away I like this one and the
interesting thing I've noticed following
the mailing list for a while is the
constant inflow of people saying that go
absolutely needs such-and-such a feature
from such-and-such language and there
was also this thread which I thought was
kind of apt
alright so that was yesterday today and
in the intervening years we're now kind
of at this position where we see
articles like this one from red monk
that was titled go to the emerging
language of cloud infrastructure which I
think Derrick might say something about
maybe and I was really encouraged by
this graph which shows the percentage of
go language use on Olav which is the
open source language stats website and
one of them on yes we might be at one
now I'm not sure but the interesting
thing about this graph it looks like
ogee we're heading to 1% but when you
consider that all of the other like
mainstream languages like C++ Java and
so on they're only at like 10% or less
each apiece right so approaching 1/10 of
C is pretty substantial we also have
tons of user groups including this one I
visited probably nearly 20 of them
around the world and they continue to
spring up and I think it's one of the
most sort of rewarding and satisfying
things about being involved in go is
visiting these groups all around the
world and seeing like-minded people get
together and an embrace go and we also
had gopher Khan was anyone in this room
at gopher Khan yeah all right so it was
it awesome yeah yeah okay yes it was it
was great for those of you who went
there it was a three-day event we had
700 people sold out 24 talks we had
panel and amazingly like on the third
day on the hack day we had 4 hours
straight of lightning talks from the
community just people who spontaneously
signed up to speak we just had a ton of
people really excited to talk about all
the cool stuff they were doing in going
so that was great yeah yes sir
Eric one of the organizers is here
the other was with Brian Kittleson who's
also deserves applause oh wait wait a my
slides good oh yeah yeah yeah no sorry I
apologize okay
so the attitudes to the gopher have also
changed we now have the girlfriend
various incarnations the most sort of
famous being the plush gopher we now
have him in three colors although I'm
told but apparently if you're colorblind
the purple and blue look the same which
is kind of hilarious we offered one of
our contributors a new purple go friend
he was like I've already got one of
those and you know the Gophers also been
in in large sizes the core OS gopher bus
which is totally amazing and blew
everyone away especially Rene it was the
designer of the Gopher who's thrilled
and you know I think if there's any
testament to the success of our mascot
it's this this was soon and I'm not
gonna try and pronounce from the
Netherlands who yeah he did that which
you know I'm not a tattoo guy it's not
really my thing but it's pretty amazing
although I used to probably mention that
while that is definitely the first
tattooed go gopher
it's not the first of Renee's creations
to be tattooed there you go and so go
1.3 was released last week has anybody
not installed this yet
thank you uh you could have leave so
that was you know six months in the
making or six months in a couple of
weeks we missed the date by 18 days
sorry but there's a lot of cool stuff
baked in you know Native Client support
which is not the runs in Google Chrome
Native Client support it's the runs code
safely in a sandboxed environment Native
Client support so we use that on the go
play ground and in the tour and so on to
say if the execute code and there are
there's a lot of scope to use that
another kind of context to and we've got
their support for some new operating
systems which all came from the
community which was great
you know a lot of performance
improvements probably the most notable
being the different stack management
mechanism which actually leads into this
precise GC of stacks we did this
contiguous stacks instead of segmented
stacks so that we could track no no
what's the guy amirite yeah yeah yeah
yeah so sorry that we can do the precise
JC oh no its other way around yeah we
needed we we needed to do the precise
gist of sex to do the contiguous stacks
which performs better and will be a
benefit overall we moved part of the
linker into the compilers so that
incremental builds happen faster because
take making less work for linker and
something that people are really excited
about and I'm excited about is their
static analysis tools so that's where
we're at today and I just like to spend
a little bit of time talking about kind
of where we're headed in the future so
we've got a couple of upcoming dedicated
Goa conferences we've got go in Paris is
anyone going to that the three other
people were speaking and there's also go
freak on India which is happening in
February 2015
so those are both really exciting and I
guess the the next thing on the horizon
for the NGO community is go one point
four which is June and just under six
months from now and so I just like to
talk a little bit about what we're
hoping will appear in it so this is a
list of new language features nope isn't
a new keyword it's just so I'm just
saying that there are no I'm sorry
oh yeah there could be not that's yeah
cleaner yeah okay
there's a proposal to canonicalize input
paths so if you use vanity import i'll
say with with camlistore
you can import packages from family sort
or org slash slash bar that's actually
using a little trick which is documented
in the go tool it's actually an alias
for this source repository hosted here
on google sauce hook on and what this
what the canonical import path mechanism
which has not been decided it's just
being proposed what it will allow is for
you to specify in your repository what
the canonical base path of that
repository is and so if you check out
the code from say if i try to check out
candy store from this pup it would give
me an error or it would just
transparently check it out into the
right place and what this lets us do is
if we want to move something from one
from one actual place to another we can
be sure that everyone is still just
using it from the same canonical import
path and which will save us a lot of
trouble it's also going to have a nice
effect on github supporting model
because a big source of pain a lot of
people is they fork a github repo and
suddenly all the import paths change if
you're using go get I'm sure as anybody
experience that problem before yeah a
few people right and so you know the way
to get around that today is you can just
change the git remote
I'm using the git command but keep the
code in the original place even though
you're working on a fork but what this
will allow us to do is actually specify
when we're forking the code just to
spend a full just to send a pull request
or whether we actually intend to fork
the code and have it live at a new
location
so that's that's the idea another
proposal which is currently kind of
generating some further in the Girling
dev mailing list is this internal
packages proposal and that's the ability
to have packages that can only be
imported by sort of peers in the same
repository or under the same car okay
and the main use case for this right now
is that we're working towards
translating the go compiler from C to go
and as part of that the compiler will
comprise be comprised of multiple
packages and we want to be able to
define packages for the implementation
of the compiler but we don't want people
like outside of the compiler to be
importing those packages and so there
are a lot of cases where splitting
things up into packages makes sense but
it doesn't actually make sense for you
to define an interface that is then
exported to the rest of the world and
then you know people can just use
because it's not necessarily gonna be
used properly and we're gonna move the
standard library inside the repository
from source package to just slash source
so the structure will be much more like
a normal go workspace or go path not
much more to say about that
we'd like to implement some throttling
on file system access so currently right
now if you just launched a million go
routines that open a million files you
end up spinning up a million operating
system threads and your program dies
what we'd like to do is make that work
similar to how networking works where
the the OS package will actually
throttle access to the file system so
that only you know a sane amount of
operating system threads are actually
opened and so it means that you can kind
of write the naive obviously correct
code to just kind of hand me a file
system without actually hammering your
file system which should be quite nice
there's a proposal which is forthcoming
to introduce a go generate command and
so this is seen to be a convenience for
generating those source files from
various sources like using yak or
generating protobuf code or embedding
HTML files or binary files and go in go
packages and there are other ideas that
you could imagine that this kind of
cogeneration could be used for and the
idea is you have some directives than
you go sauce files and you use go
generate and the package name to
regenerate those source files so expect
a proposal in the next few days on that
school there's also a bunch more
toolchain work coming support for GCC
grow in in within the go tool and that
means Jesus ego being able to compile
the go tool and that should make it a
lot easier people to use GCC go support
to just embed data files directly in go
programs via the linker so we're not
having to first translate files into go
source code before embedding them in
some improvements the race detective and
of course continuing the transition from
C to go we hope we've already started
rewriting the linker in go there's an
assembly rewrite on the way as well and
we might have the translation of the of
GCC the compiler in Tagore Dimitri is
going to work on a better garbage
collector and memory allocator so the
original the current memory allocator is
based on TC malloc which is a c++ memory
allocator basically but there's
definitely other things we can do to
make it more go oriented there will be
better performance and there are some
other ways to reduce reduce GC pause
time by doing the concurrent sweet phase
which kind of ties in to that kind of
work
what are you saying it's already done
I told you to look at these slides and
you didn't say anything thanks a lot
Dimitri well it's already done then
sorry I was looking at their own design
dog okay um yeah and so we want to see
some more runtime changes this stuff
hasn't been done though right
yeah good okay so stop doing stuff
without telling me Cheers and yeah we
want we want to also start converting
the the runtime part of the runtime as
well from C to go and there's a bunch of
package changes on the horizon as well
maybe some better structuring features
in the template package so being able to
have templates that inherit from other
templates and some other kind of
efficiency things and Unicode seven
support but god knows what that means
I know also there's people who want to
work on Native Client forearm and
PowerPC 64 and also arm 64 support and
that kind of ties into another
interesting feature which is go support
for Android dev pro show is here is
working on providing go support to
Android in the same way that C and C++
are supported and you buy the NDK and
the goal is to be able to write games so
we'd like to provide some kind of
framework for running games and it's
based on the great work of Elias an hour
and others from the community and you
can follow that link to see more about
it there's also a longer list of to dues
which is the go 14 to do dock going
august lash s /k 14 to do and I could
probably take a question I think I've
run over time
anyone have anything didn't I mention
them already okay